hey everyone it's my kobato's and
welcome to the oracles market analysis
for Friday September 1st 2017 first
trading day of the month and the big
thing on the calendar was the non-farm
payroll numbers and they came in soft
it showed a growth of 156 thousand vs.
market expectations of 180,000 one part
of it that was especially soft where the
average hourly earnings which were up
just 0.1 percent higher for the month
and year on year rate was at 2.5% you
know both slightly below expectations
but pointing to continued trouble for
wages and inflation the Dow ended up the
week up about just under 1% we ended up
yesterday a 0.2% higher oil you know
despite Hurricane Harvey actually fell
for the week it was down about 50 cents
at 47 31 although of course you know
gasoline futures that's the one that you
really got to be keeping an eye on we're
up 20 cents to a buck 74 gold had a nice
solid week we're up to and about just
over two and a half percent at 13:30 and
you know for the year gold is up about
15% you know so it's putting in a nice
rally this year so anyway this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain status or risk is
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
ones financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results again the
tools we use the same tools we use every
day it's the order flows trainer volume
footprint chart and the Delta scalper
which is a tool to help you understand
the Delta in the market you know Delta
is an important part of order flow
measures the net aggressive buying and
aggressive selling so you know it gives
you a number and you can actually use
that in your trading you know everyone
is focused on price but you know there's
other things to be focused on besides
price is volume there's aggressive
buyer's or seller's there's imbalances
there's a lot of other things to focus
on and you know majority of traders just
focus on price they treat all price
is the same when not all prices are
actually the same you know when you
treat you treat a price of 47 the same
if you knew only one lot traded or 50
Lots or 1000 Lots you know if everyone's
gonna have a slightly different view if
it trades one lot or if it trades a
thousand Lots so anyway that's said
let's jump in and take a look at some of
these markets today give me a sec okay
so first market I'll talk about this
morning is uh it's the bonds again you
know seven 30s when the number came out
and you know it's a big number in terms
of market reaction I actually like to
wait about 15 minutes for this market to
settle down any you know for the bonds
recipes like they'll let the market
settle down after the non-farm payroll
number comes out I'll give it off at
least 15 minutes so I wouldn't you know
start I don't like to trade on that
number because even though the reaction
yesterday was quite muted you know part
of the reason is because it's a long
weekend I think traders were just sort
of you know putting in face time in the
office like hey I'm here okay
number came out now I believe early go
on my holiday for the long weekend so
you know it was a bit muted today in
terms of market reaction I mean there's
times where we used to get 10 points
wings and the ESPYs the good old days
now you don't really get yesterday you
didn't get much even the bonds you know
we popped up to the high right after the
number and literally sold off within you
know 15 minutes from our highs down into
new lows you know so when I say it was
muted getting a very tight range was
that 150 612 down to 150 524 but you
know nevertheless you sold off from your
highs down to your lows now it got a bit
interesting down here first you know 8
o'clock I looking at this thinking this
was bullish you got your divergence you
got eurasian on the next bar you got
your delta scalper here it to me it was
like all systems go
you sort of had some nice delta in here
542 you know 20-22 that's good that's
small it's nothing major 491 300 they
can ok you know maybe now we could start
pulling away what happens boom you just
sell right off into
new lows this Delta here in this bar I
thought was very bullish you know his -
1471 at one point and it ended up at
plus 3 3 3 so you know 1 4 - 1400 almost
- 1500 - plus 300 the swing of 1500 in
the Delta but nevertheless it came right
back down selling happened faster you
had a nice big Delta in this bar 797 yet
you closed lower that's not a good sign
there's actually a very bearish sign
next bar start selling off boom boom
boom you start coming down into the new
lows at 9 o'clock and you had some other
stuff coming out at 9 o'clock
you got a bit of a reaction here you've
got this stacked imbalance here you got
nothing you have a don't have a ratio
you got a second slide in balance I mean
you got some trapped traders down here
you know people markets selling off
everyone's coming in piling and piling
in sells some more sell some more you
got that imbalance here but the market
snapback got a nice little bounce up
here then you got down into this low
down here at 910 Delta scalper right on
the low divergence point of control
towards the bottom I don't like the fact
that he came right back with in there
and negative ratio of bearish ratio
right after the fact but I do like the
fact that you came down tested the low
again trade to less volume the second
time 233 on the bid side 185 you go and
offered here 358 but really what I'm
looking at is the bid versus the bid
there and it couldn't be said it traded
less but obviously it turned off heard
there which sort of you know is one of
those things that you know it's turned
offer but why didn't it hit why didn't
anyone trade just one lot down here at
at 29 you know no one was interested
market started coming back up boom boom
you know some small Delta's in here 61
102 you know negative Delta 499 449 but
bar still turned up so that indicates to
me some supportive buying you know even
here you got a couple imbalances got an
imbalance here then this bar has seen
some imbalances you know by this point
you should be thinking hey this mark is
probably going to you know put in a
little bit of rally you know you could
be looking to get in around the 1011
area and you'll eventually trades all
the way up into the up to 21 you got a
bearish ratio here nice and negative
delta 800 you got the price rejecter
kicking off there
next bar negative Delta it's a doji bar
and then we start coming back down you
know so you had some reasons to be
buying not necessarily down here I mean
yeah you could take your shot with that
Delta scalper by itself down here right
off this low you know that's perfectly
fine but again you know for some people
you know they might not be convinced
that this is going to be the low but by
the time you get to this bar here you
know you should already be convinced
that hey we're moving up you know you've
seen how these you're putting in the
higher opponent controls already you
know you're even earlier you had some
higher opponent controls here but this
you know these three bars nice higher
opponent controls so by now you should
be thinking hey we're gonna get a little
bit of a rally you said you got 10
points 10 ticks rather you know up to
the 21 area then you got your negative
sign up here you got your price rejecter
you got your bearish ratio strong
negative Delta next bar negative Delta
again you know point of control up near
the top of the bar and you can start
thinking you know hey if you're a long
it's time to get out again you could
also even look at possible shorts right
there as you come back down going into
the clothes for the day okay so you know
let's look at the five years yeah and
you know kind of similar to the bonds
you know we propped up made new highs
right after the number sold off down
into new lows let's take a look at these
lows here a little bit similar to the
you know what you were seeing in the
bonds earlier this time though you have
the ratio and divergence in the bar you
know Delta scalper afterwards and you're
looking for this market to start
rallying it doesn't it just comes right
back down you got the side-by-side point
controls you know this one just now
fails you come in at 9 o'clock though
you know nine o'clock you had came out
is M I believe it was yeah so a consumer
sentiment coming out at nine o'clock
that's why this market is kind of in
fast market mode here at nine o'clock
but again you know you got this bar here
Rachel bonds low ratio and divergence
I'm not saying that you would have
bought it being on the buy it right in
here or something really early by the
time you you know this markets moving
very fast at this time I don't have the
the x on here seconds but I see it's all
nine o'clock you know we do come down
and test these you know test the lows
and you
down within two ticks both times here
you're seeing some massive volume what
does the volume profile look like
actually your point control is as up
here actually at was that 11 and 3/4 but
when you're down here he said that this
volume 3000 even here you know 10,000
3,000 3,000 5,000 right so you know
there's support down here you got a
racial bounds though you got a nice
candle I love these candles right you
got again very bearish at one point -
5519 five and a half thousand negative
Delta at one point in this bar and is up
at positive 858 so you see a swing in
the Delta
that's quite massive you know almost
6,000 lots over 6,000 lots a buying came
in and that's buried in that information
you know if you're just looking at
normal Candlestick you're not gonna see
that information that's why I say you
know Delta is a very powerful tool what
happens you get a nice rally up an X bar
a bunch of imbalances to X bar you guys
stacked buying and balance up in here
but you run back up into a bearish ratio
you run into the price rejecter and then
you start selling off you have a not a
stacked imbalance but you got one two
three imbalances in this bar which is
still negative I mean you could still
treat that as a stack imbalance it's
just technically they're not stacked on
top of each other because you got this
one price level in here was 732 against
569 that this is not an imbalance but
you still got multiple imbalances in
there which is still bearish so you know
and it's coming in at the area where you
just had your stack buying imbalance so
you know at this point everything is
shifted right now you got aggressive
sellers coming in where earlier I had
aggressive buyers so even if you're long
of these aggressive buyers you know
thinking these markets gonna go higher
when you're just all of a sudden staring
at aggressive sellers at the same price
that's going to be negative and the
market sells off a bit down into the
clothes okay so the next market talk
about euro currency for a sec here again
you know this is 7:30
you know markets moving very fast for
fast market mode like I said I'd like to
give it about 15 minutes or so does
settle down get its footing still moving
very fast at this point you know you're
getting a bar every you know 10 seconds
so
I still know it's moving very fast as an
eight range chart but you know when you
start getting into a point like this
right you're kind of going sideways
right notice all the delt that's what is
it it's positive or negative its
negative I take this I don't really like
looking at cumulative Delta and what you
got going sideways also now it starts
turning positive and you've seen some
signs of life you know this is like EKG
doo doo doo doo now let's turn positive
in here
all right you starting string together
bars the positive Delta and as you are
you're starting to see the aggressive
buying taking over and the market starts
going higher here you got the Delta
scalper given a sell didn't work out
didn't go up make a new high before
finally selling off again here you got
the price rejecter given the sell you
come down to the swing low here you got
a price rejecter give it another sell
you a little bit of a sell off about 10
you know ten full ticks and Delta
scalper giving you a couple buys here
just going sideways on you
Delta scalper give you a buy
unfortunately just sort of went sideways
on you how can you tell the markets
going sideways on you as you look at the
point controls are they starting to line
up almost you know at the same level
over several bars then yeah the markets
going sideways because you're putting in
you know a value area right here for
this time period putting in a value area
right at that price those prices then
you get down here to this low this was
at 8:40 again you know I you have some
volume going through you got this
imbalance 127 64 but you don't have a
bullish ratio you don't have a
divergence you get down here you put it
in a new low
you've got again you got a ratio but no
divergence next bar you got the Delta
scalper but it comes right back here
with a negative sign you got the bearish
ratio you got point of control up near
the top so even though you get a little
bit excited about seeing this Delta
scalper by looking at what you see in
the order flow you know
this chance is probably not gonna work
out and it doesn't it fails get down
here you got a new low still negative
Delta it is a ratio but you know nothing
that you really like about it again you
know 854 again you got some numbers
coming out in a few minutes nine o'clock
the market drops some more when the
consumer sentiment and is M comes out so
again fast market you know you're
talking you know how many these bars are
forming over one or two seconds you know
quite fast 9:02 the markets still moving
a bit fast Delta scalper gives you a
nice little buy here Delta scupper gives
you a sell here about a minute later
that fails you start rallying up again
starts trading back and forth Delta
scalper sell doesn't work out this one
works out a little bit and you got to
buy here this buyer was a bit nicer you
know your talk in the ad area eighty-two
area eventually we rally start putting
in this nice rally up into you know
above one nineteen even start coming off
again now I was it's here so we're
looking at ten o'clock here okay and
what do you see okay just go back here I
mean you see some positive Delta's here
but then you see negative negative one
positive negative negative negative
negative negative negative okay and
you're starting to finally starting to
come off would you be looking to buy or
be looking to sell you know we would
rather be positioned longer short with
all this negative Delta you should be
look thinking about being short you know
you get a little bit of a bounce up here
with this buying aggressive buying the
Delta is two to three but then again
negative negative negative negative
negative and we start selling off you
know when you start stringing together a
lot of negative Delta's chances are the
markets gonna sell off its not gonna
rally unless they start stringing
together their positive Delta's you know
here you got point of control on the
bottom which is bullish again you get
this nice nice move up off I don't say
off of this but because did make it a
new tick low here but again you know I
find these bars very very bullish when
it's on the bottom part of control on
the bottom I thought of doing a
presentation just today on pointing
control on the extremes you know when he
got here a point of control on the
stream right here point control on the
low point of control on the high and you
get a little move bar necklace are down
the next bar up though
Delta's copper you don't give you a sell
here
did make new highs but then you got
another cell here at you know you know
what prices this around the 88 area 87
and boom you started selling off and
look at this on this move down all
negative deltas 161 101 28 8 small here
but 106 84 123 and so on as you start
selling off again when in control
towards the low here that's what this
line is for just to alert me want to
control up near the top of this bar and
you know that's how we went out not just
show you the Delta dax really quick
again this is just the Delta scalper
indicator and I just sort of walk it
back here
so again you know 6:40 this morning we
get a nice sell up here what is this
price around the 165 area sells all the
way down into the 130s you know just
before the number came out you know one
40s I I would not want to hold it
dax through a major number like that but
call me a or whatever but you know
I've I've lost I've made money on
numbers and I've lost money on numbers I
just prefer to not have the heart attack
during the numbers there's one time I
was trading Eurodollar futures not the
euro currency the euro dollars futures
which and and the front month which is
extremely slow I held it through a
number then non-farm payrolls this is
back in the 90s and I got a move they
have a three ticks a whopping three
ticks on the number and it was just
wasn't a big position or anything like
that it was just like five or those five
or 10 contracts but you know I had I had
a corresponding position and say the
bonds you know you're talking a full a
full basis point you know but you know
that's that's basically one of the only
things I'd hold through non-farm
payrolls is is a hero is a short-term
interest rate because you're not gonna
get the the big the big moves that you
would get on things that are more
volatile but you can see how the market
you know from 7:30 he sold off a bit
your low here in the dax
over the next 15 minutes you rally back
up you know another you know it's 25
ticks right there so you got some small
cells here that fail fail fail fail fail
fail I shouldn't show you this but now I
gotta show you this because you do get
you know even though you have losing
trades right you also get some nice
winning trades you know so boom you know
you're getting short here you know this
is 165 you get a moved on into the 140s
so you know while you do have you know
small losing trades it's all about
managing your trades right you have to
manage your trades know your risk to
reward ratio and understand you know the
cut you everyone you hear that term so
much I've gotta cut your losses short
you know your losses keep you off as
small and let your winners ride you know
I prefer to you know fine trades that
happen really quick you know big moves
really quick and you know take the small
losses when they stopped me out
immediately I'm not necessarily big fan
of riding up and down like this you know
having to stop down here trail your stop
you trail it and let the market take you
out if it's not going in your favor so
you know you'd still have you know a
small winner here you know on this trade
right here I mean some like this is just
pure loser that's a pure loser this is a
pure loser but you know it's happening
fast right once you start training you
can't understand or you're gonna have
losses in your training I mean I hey
yeah I don't wanna discourage people but
you know not every trade is going to be
a night if you train you take is going
to be a winner you know I mean I said
you know people like to not lose they
like to always have winning trades but
at the end of the day you know not all
trades are gonna be winners you know
it's all about maximizing your winners
and minimizing your losers okay so let
me see if I got a another chart I can
show you here really quick bear with me
here I talked about the euro currency
already
it's a crude oil okay
and this is a 233 tick chart you know
very fast chart you know talking about
hit and run you know to me that's what
if you're trading a 233 tick chart and
crude to me that's like hit and run
training so you know you gotta be taking
small you know cross a small trades
gonna take you know trades that you're
not necessarily to be holding for a long
time period
alright so like here you know you get a
nice move up here ninety-six up to you
know the 10 area yeah a little move here
a little move here a little move there
honestly I don't reason I look at this
tick chart is because you know I had a
user says it doesn't work on on 233 tick
chart the Delta scalpel and I'm like no
man it does I don't know how he's
trading honestly you know people just
send me e-mail say oh it doesn't work on
the 233 tick chart period but they don't
tell me you know what their duration is
like how long they're willing to hold
the trade what their profit target is
because you know what if you know yeah
you can get something you know if you're
getting you know short here on this bar
and the market starts coming back up you
know you have a buy signal ok so you get
out all right
here you got to buy and you guys sell
signal you get out you know you get
short you know here's a buy signal ya
worked out a little bit then you got a
sell signal so you know after you get in
you get out then there you got a
beautiful buy signal 46 so that is 75
area all the way up literally straight
up you know it's it's almost like these
you know I again you know people don't
share with me necessarily their trades
but based on what I read from them on
the feedback it's like yeah I had this
trade here and you know I got long at 75
and I got out here okay that's fine you
got out at 93 we'll call it 95 so keep
them that simple that's 20 ticks and
then you know the kid said I got short
here off this bar here at we'll call it
75 we'll keep it simple but I got
stopped out up here you know at 80 or so
we'll call it 80 well why are you
getting
doubt up here you know yet another buy
signal and in the meantime you know you
can here is another nice trade you know
little bit i bought here at 13 okay what
did you get out I got out it
I had my stop at 13 so I broke even on
the trade so you know I might have
believed I mean it's not this am I to
believe obviously that's what happens
what you telling me is you got long at
13 and then the market is just going
sideways up in here for you know however
long for five minutes and you didn't
think about getting out you know cuz you
got greedy because you thought the
market was gonna go higher when the
markets going sideways now that's your
time to get out you know that market is
I don't say thinking about what it wants
to do next but you know it's found an
area of value then it's going to search
for another area of value you know so
it's to say you know they have a trade
like this and get out at breakeven is is
kind of you know not good trade
management's I don't say bad trading but
it's it's just not good trade management
you know here's another nice move you
know so I mean here you get chopped up
you know here here here you have three
losers four losers here but then boom
you lose in five ten fifteen twenty
cents here but then you know you're
getting it back in here mostly on this
trade then later you get back some more
here you know from 28 all the way down
to you know this is this area 14 so it's
another 15 ticks it's all about trade
management you know and trailing your
stops and understanding that but again
you know I I don't I'm not a big fan of
training a 233 tick chart and on crude
oil but yeah I keep it up I and I show
you know people because they opiod it
doesn't work on this chart well it does
actually and it comes down to your
trading abilities I mean I hate to say
that but you know trading is not easy if
it was easy everyone would do it I mean
that sounds cliche but it's it's the
fact it's kind of a debating right now
whether actually put in posting this
video up or not actually but I mean I'm
sure you know somebody some of you guys
will agree with what I had to say there
okay so this is it yen real quick
okay so this is seven thirty this is
when the number come
came out come out came out CeCe's fast
market zod zeros prints in here
7:32 got your hi your racial divergence
Delta scalper afterwards Delta surged
here but again you know honestly you
know who's giving you the cell signal I
wouldn't be looking at trading net at
7:30 to two minutes after the number
come out came out come on that's one
with my English today I like to give it
at least 15 minutes for the market to
settle down so you know 7:45 here things
are a little bit more clear you got a
nice Delta scalper by here you got a
nice little move up getting some bearish
signs up in here you got Delta surge
here you got some trap traders in this
bar no market sold off a bit here Delta
surge coming Delta scalper rather giving
you another sell signal there but then
you got the price rejecter coming in
here a nice another move higher I've got
a couple of things here you got the
stacked imbalance you've got a bullish
ratio you've got the Delta scalper
giving you a buy signal and then you get
a nice move up here before you start
making your move back down now there's
interesting in this bar these barks hear
you're moving lower on positive deltas
you see all these binding balances in
here one of the reason why you see these
binding balances that I have my volume
and balance threshold set to one so you
gonna see two against 13 you're gonna
see one against eight technically those
are imbalances but you know take them
with a grain of salt but anyway you
start coming down why because you have
super awesome you call that resistance
selling up in here you got some decent
volume in some of these bars 4550 13850
107 that's holding the market down and
when desire I said markets not selling
off on strong positive Delta Z these are
small 61 23 14 20 so you know that
there's passive sellers you know there's
sellers with supply up here either being
offered out 4550 13850 107 21 that's why
you have the positive deltas because
there was buying into those offers and
the market sells off get down to this
low here you got doji bar I'm not a big
fan of those G's but eventually do come
down at nine o'clock
when the other nother set of numbers
came out quite a violent move down again
906 here evenly got racial and
divergence there and market did rally
I'm not gonna say that was that was a
big buy even though it was it that was
the signal that you like to see later in
the day here here so you get up to this
bar
you got 272 negative Delta then you get
this bar here you got a lot of trapped
traders up here 36 36 100 185 and then
the selling comes in the aggressive
selling comes at 107 140 986 and he
starts selling off again and then you
just sort of go into the clothes and you
end out the day there so you know this
this area up in here I thought was
interesting you know this is what trap
traders look like it's you know it's
what it is it's volume on the top on the
offer side at a high of a move that's
what trap traders are people everyone
buying things as markets going higher
but they're wrong and then the market
reverses and sells off you know and you
often get positive Delta you don't get
negative Delta necessarily when you got
trapped traders because all these people
you know you hear the term you know when
you're when you buy you become a seller
because you bought then eventually you
got to sell to get out yeah if you're a
day trader yes of course your short term
trader yes you bought and you're
thinking I gotta get out before the
close because you bought here think that
the markets going higher but the markets
not going higher so you can become a
seller and you're gonna be aggressive
seller you're gonna get out you're gonna
capitulate and get out that's why the
market comes off when you have trapped
traders like that up there
okay so just really quick this is the
decks the uni Renko chart and you know
just going back to post 7:30 I mean you
don't have some trades here you know
this one doesn't work out that doesn't
work out you got a nice winner here but
730 just sort of spin your wheels around
a bit you know you got this chopped
yeah nice buy here this is it 7-3 all
the time that was 7:35 again you know I
like too late let it settle itself down
I give it about 15 minutes
so yeah I would have missed this trade
um I'm not gonna be someone says oh yeah
you know you'd get long on the number
and you write it up all the way no um
you know I say I've I've been in the
market long enough and I've been burned
a few times on the numbers that I know
not to trade them for me now that's
what's called trading discipline and I
knowing myself and knowing how I trade
that it's it's not good for me to do but
anyway you know later on you know 750 a
nice buy here you got another nice buy
here you come back down got up here you
gotta sell this one that workout and
then I sell here another nice sell here
this sell didn't work out that sell
didn't work out this sell a little bit
here right here this one did this one
didn't then you know then I sell down
here you know where are we this is the
close but again you know you get another
nice trade here you know familiy the 160
175 area 165 all the way down into the
135 you know so you're getting some nice
nice trades on the tax you know I think
the DAX is a great market to trade it is
it is a margin hog you know as you're
talking in 20-some thousand euros
contract but you don't need to be
trading a shitload the contracts you
know you could be trading one one
contract and you know if you're
positioned right you could have a
breakthrough today you have good days
you know where you're getting you know
quite a few ticks okay so thanks
everyone for watching this video and
have a good weekend they said it said so
Labor Day weekend this weekend so you
know markets futures markets will be
open they'll be on those the holiday
schedule check the seamy websites you
know Sunday night will reopen everything
will be trade day Tuesday though Tuesday
the 4th sorry Tuesday the fifth rather
than there's no there's no settlements
on Monday you know then it'll close in
the around early morning and then reopen
as a Sunday schedule so thanks for
watching this and to learn more about
trading with order flow visit my web
site order closed calm also on learn
more about the Delta scalper go to Delta
scalper calm and be sure to subscribe to
the YouTube channel and you'll be
notified when new videos are posted so
thanks
have a good and safe holiday bye-bye